bonjour et merci d'être avec nous par
téléphone sur rtl france ce matin votre
commune a vécu la fermeture d'une
sucrerie en janvier dernier vous êtes
donc directement concernés par le sujet
est les députés ont-ils pris une bonne
décision en votant cette disposition
bien sûr qu'ils ont pris une bonne
décision parce que malheureusement nous
avons vécu fermeture du titre sur notre
sommet l'année dernière mais si cette
décision n'avait pas été pris c'est tout
un pan d'activité économie qui tourne
autour de la betterave qui se serait
effondré et on aurait connu la fermeture
d'autres villes dans notre région nous
ici au sud de paris
il reste encore cinq failles sucreries
et je suis sûr que si cette décision
n'avait pas été prise de remettre en
action les néonicotinoïdes le temps de
trouver des alternatives au niveau des
semences de betteraves et bien nous
aurions b vécu d'autres fermetures de
sites du fait que les producteurs et
vous l'avez très bien résumé dans dans
votre introduction aurait souhaité
arrêter la production de betteraves paso
concrètement quel a été l'impact de
cette fermeture de cette sucrerie pour
votre commune et pour ses habitants
et bien tout simplement un impact
économique et social quand vous fermez
une entreprise quelle qu'elle soit eh
bien vous avez toute la politique
sociale de la commune les gens les gens
qui sont ici travail qui n'ont plus
d'emploi qui se retrouvent au chômage
mbia compliqué donc s'assurer qu'elles
un impact économique et sociétal
important
alors il faut préserver les agriculteurs
et la filière de la betterave est ce que
les conséquences environnementales de 7h
et autorisation des néonicotinoïdes en
valent la peine
tout à fait la betterave est par
définition la betterave qui
il est produit pour faire du sucre ne
crée pas de fleurs donc sur les champs
de betteraves vous avez par définition
pas d'abeilles qui viennent d' utiliser
puisqu'il n'y a pas de chef donc au
regard de ce qui a été proposé avec des
consignes particulières sur le retour
l'année n de plantes qui ne t'ont
pas à fleurs sur les cultures eh bien
c'est une bonne chose et il y aura pas
d'impact autre chose s'il ne faut pas
oublier dans le fonctionnement général
cette filière et les déshydratation qui
déshydrate delà de la paix tram à la
période automnale déshydrate également
de la luzerne
pendant toute la période estivale au
printemps et à l'été et est donc pour ce
qui concerne notre secteur
s'il y avait plus de betteraves plus de
sucreries plus de sucreries plus de
déshydratation plus de déshydratation
plus de luzerne et à côté de ça la
luzerne est une plante très valorisant
pour le pour les abeilles pour qu'elles
puissent butiner
donc il faut pas regarder eux juste un
sujet bien précis pour garder son sujet
le sujet dans son ensemble et je pense
et j'ai pu échanger avec des apiculteurs
que globalement la betterave n'est pas
n'est pas le problème par contre la
perte de l'une d'elles serait dramatique
pour leur production de miel
localement il est possible selon vous
trouver un juste équilibre entre
protection de l'environnement et
développement économique et agricole
bien sûr mais l'agriculture - moi
j'habite à la campagne il faut que
l'agriculture les agriculteurs et le
monde agricole depuis des années
maintenant ont de gros efforts
environnementaux
je pense que c'est ce qu'ils font le
plus d'efforts environnementaux ils sont
ils sont montrés du doigt sur des en
reprenant des sujets qui tâte je puis
m'exprimer de mathusalem le le progrès
agricole a été tel que je pense que
c'est ils font partie de ce qu'il fonde
le plus gros effort au niveau
environnemental pour justement
e&d assez transition écologique merci
pour votre réaction laurent leclerc
maire de toury commune de l'eure et loir